hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whack the burglars now
you guys mentioned when I played whack
the boss superhero edition which you can
see in the link in the description below
if you haven't seen already then I
missed out on this one and I figured
with my brand-new blood red hair what
better way to celebrate than beating all
the blood out of poor unsuspecting
burglars yes they're the victims here
look they just look so fun to have a
good time I don't even know what they
said there I don't even know what
ethnicity they are Oh what I don't have
a bed I got a pretty good guard dog
though find a way to kill all the
burglars okay fine else need to turn on
my mouse what thing okay much better now
alright how am I going to murder you
horribly this object requires a second
to work why oh this is new what what am
I gonna use with the candelabra this is
a three item combo don't miss her there
will be consequences huh
talking about Oh God oh why my my dog is
just looking at me like well I guess I'm
gonna need a new owner now damn it Lego
an incompetent death you activated your
first fail kill before actually killed
the burglar I'm a loser baby oh god I
don't want to share this to Facebook
yeah dad fire okay now we're gonna get
to the heart of the issue here which is
this guy that's not exactly a fireplace
that's that's fire power
[Music]
there was so many bullets that it lagged
out the computer and couldn't stop
looping through oh boy okay let's not do
a three-one combo let's try to find the
solution to make this candelabra work
movie movie plus why I don't know what
the movie plus I don't know movie post
game oh my god why's there gotta be
combo systems I'm not smart enough to
figure this out I'm barely smart enough
to press buttons oh hey it worked
of course the remote in the movie Oh
around
[Music]
oh oh it's just gonna stay here we're
gonna be watching this for a long time
he's gaping and beer aww and ecstasy at
working that he's seen before him oh my
god
horrifying game console class I don't
know Hey Dude are you doing there oh god
this is made by the same guy that made
wack your neighbors Wow
whack your neighbor also in the
description and the man he kind of
improved on his style a little bit he or
she whoever made it I have no idea
maybe it was a team damn so are there
gonna be just you activated your first
combo kill hi Danny
I get it with the bits of a beam of the
movie in the road I don't need to share
that you're dumb and I don't like you
mirror okay
mirror mirror on the wall who's the
dentist of the mouth
oh what's that entirely necessary I mean
I guess the alternative is that who's
gonna shoot you in the face I don't know
why he's just taking the time to let you
do that oh there we go okay I got it
oh that's good okay
the non-lethal solution the best of them
all this is gonna go great ray no one
died okay I forget that
go get him whiskey wait do I combine him
with the whiskey his name is whiskey I
can combine him with whiskey it seems
like you've done to you oh okay by then
I guess everything's oh geez I guess
it's not oh that's pretty bad oh well
[Applause]
thanks grandma you have a good day
grandma don't worry I'll clean up this
mess grandma what did you do whiskey
you're trembling in fear oh my god all
right what about this bear bear and what
else it's a complicated son of a [ __ ] I
[Music]
got one oh I got one what that's not oh
he's that stupid he's just gonna start
picking him up oh oh god damn it
[Music]
how does that work how did he blow
through the sand labra oh okay right on
ah what a tasty cigar I think oh no wait
the poker was also deadly and let that
be a lesson smoking kills or something
like that lamp I don't know how you're
gonna be devious about this one for that
one
you must have super-strength you said it
right through his heart
god damn ah there we go cat and dog have
Adam boys it's not okay oh man that cat
did a number on it I mean the dog did
too I don't exactly know what organ that
is on the ground over there but I don't
know hundred proof whiskey I'm not gonna
breathe fire in his face no I'm just
gonna beat him in the face with it be a
little uncreated oh I'm gonna light him
on fire there you go
oh that's horrifying oh there we go
curtains and a baseball bat
you know these logically don't go well
together no no I have a gun but I'm not
gonna use it
[Music]
okay all righty then
baggy nails bagging nails we're gonna
bag of nails probably that was a thing I
got it right off the bat I mean quite
literally what wait a minute nails here
we go air freshener plus cigar on how
this epic goggles gonna work
oh yeah share with your enemy it's gotta
be good it was already lit what do you
mean is there a light it was already lit
I just busted
[Music]
I don't know if air freshener works like
that if it does I'm gonna be very much
more careful about the air freshener
dance at my own home because that seems
like it's unsafe corkscrew
let's go basic here yep just stand there
oh man he never runs away okay oh okay
it's like oh man it's like The Three
Stooges but the bloody and brutal
version is horrible it's not dead your
head I'm just gonna leave him there okay
yeah I gotta find this candelabras
situation oh oh there we go okay found
it found the one or maybe it's to I
don't know could be to what is he gonna
do I'm gonna wait five minutes for this
to happen okay you waited five minutes
for your own doom okay I'm cool with it
it's fine cushion I'm not gonna smother
him is he gonna stay there so long he's
just gonna let me smother him with a
pillow really okay
[Music]
what is happening to society what are we
taking our children why is this
happening Oh for the entertainment of
you of course oh here we go
that's a new one so the remote combo
with Oh Thomas six years old ah oh yes
okay then good thing that channel is
always available
who knows when that's actually gonna get
me alright and now I'm just gonna watch
that on TV
well I just relax on the couch at my
grandma's and the other room and my dog
watches great oh oh that's easy
that's rather simpler okay you might
want to thank you you put up your go
well oh okay that was rather inventive I
guess I could have gone up and bunch do
but I'd rather beat him with logic
things in the kitchen Oh who's where
grandma was oh hey buddy
hi buddy how are you doing I don't know
what well this rather sad music I can
already tell that this guy is regretting
all the decisions that he's made he
doesn't even want to be here he's just
trying to feed his family he's just
trying to live a good life but God's
throne to the sidelines with one too
many times and was turning a wrong
corner around a wrong bender he's not a
bad guy he's just in a bad situation
he's got a family to love and care for
he's got so many things to do in his
life and he's probably today
here we go splat I was hoping this was
gonna be quicker and a little less
dramatic it's kind of putting me in a
situation where it's not not quite so
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass bags oh god what do i
combine with it then click goddamn
everything there we go there we go
that's the dramatic sysm that I wanted
there we go
[Music]
he wasn't a bad guy he's made some bad
decisions in his life like stealing my
prized diamond my god okay all right
what else we got
kettle kettle plus what cattle plus what
do what cattle plus what do what put the
Frick stop that but I got it apparently
what that wasn't what I I had the kettle
Oh was that a triple did I do a triple
Oh baby
oh no so sad okay all righty then whoa
there we go cutting board and knives how
would I not know you stay right there I
know you're confused but just wait don't
move anywhere and let it happen really
[Music]
come on man really did he die that
punishment enough you get out of here
with that warning I'll keep your fingers
to remember you by Oh God
all right pan beat him over the head and
be done with it
oh it's almost comical I'd be laughing
it was if it wasn't horrifying sink
virgin
oh no oh god the blender oh don't do it
buddy it's not even plugged in lovely
now we got a nice pot of blood over
there hmm I got groceries
oh boy playing Oh knives yeah oh wow
that's good aim Hey good job
what are you laughing everything was
fine you just had to laugh he would have
let you go probably not he was good to
go this guy's oh there we go somehow
cheese grater iron and rolling baby I'm
gonna use the frying pan for some reason
[Music]
why what happened
did aliens abduct him and think he was
one of their own what did you do
whose Oh confuse did that one buddy
shiny Oh is that distance uh no it's
just okay was there a washing machine in
the kitchen at what point does this just
reach Pierre psychopathy
oh no that's vinegar
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to clean that up now but that's
my primary concern yes I did it but also
it has to be cleaned up you gotta open
that door eventually oh there we go
cooking stove annoying don't worry about
it that's gonna grease you up good when
I stuff your face onto the go never mind
[Music]
yep don't mind the smell of that I'll
just get a nice midnight snack
my appetite sure is hungry there we go
microwave and whatever the hell that is
again with the knocking of the out with
the extinguisher of fire alrighty then I
don't want to know what that is I don't
know 101 where am I going what am i
doing
[Applause]
[Music]
what did that do Oh what is that
Oh take it off you can take it off
what's keeping you in there yeah except
your faith
yep okay oh god oh god oh god oh god
that's how monsters from Silent Hill are
made fire extinguisher back to the
simple ones yep this old jazz no oh oh
that's all it was doesn't door I don't
know what's there something in the
basement is he gonna be in the basement
so we got to make a trip down to the
basement was in the basement Oh
48 hours later
[Music]
oh that's just sadistic at that point
okay
ah okay vinegar in the kitchen see Oh
yep here we go the old mainstay bang
okay sorry about that but I'm not sorry
at all
I'm probably gonna do something horrible
to you not that I've ever done anything
nice guys
the spider one was in that oh that's not
what vinegar do I I swear to you it was
just vinegar
you could you could drink it it's
probably fine Oh
freezer plus an ice pick of course it
was so obvious how could I not I've seen
it
thunk oh here we go hmm and then we're
gonna freeze him up and then we're gonna
you forgot his afro nice job making the
sound effects for the ding ding he's
kind of already long dead
it really was no need for that what no
hang on here that's that's not right
wait a minute I I have a few questions
about this this is breaking new ground
for science here and I feel like you
found all combo kills ray and I guess
this is the only last comment that kill
I have a feeling himself in there he
could have just good just falling down
the hole and he would have been fine oh
boy
and that's all oh god damn it you've
unlocked the savage burglar mode I don't
know what that is what am I done
what are we done what does this click
the button fast
what button what am i what am i clicking
[Music]
oh god is he still alive at first I was
playing a fun reaction time game but now
it seems like maybe can you even dodge
at this point I'm gonna try oh I missed
sorry I missed oh you got a new toy
isn't that delightful for Witzke oh my
god yay coming next whack the serial
killer
you mean you it better be whacking this
spiky haired psycho okay so that is
whack the burglar yeah I gotta admit
there's a lot of creativity in there not
good though but a lot of it so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for suggesting this game hope you
enjoyed it let me know in the comments
if he did or at least enjoyed me
squirming in agony at it but thanks
again and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]